Prof: Today we're
enjoying the first beautiful day
in quite some time.
Today we're very pleased to
have William Ryerson as our
guest speaker and he is
President of the Population
Media Center,
which by the end of the lecture
period you will know what that
is.
He graduated from Amherst
College and then he became one
of us.
He was a graduate student at
Yale studying entomology,
the ecology of insects.
In that field people seem to
realize that humans are pushing
even the insects out of
existence,
so he then became interested in
the human aspects of ecological
and population kind of things.
Thirty-three years ago he
started working in the field of
reproductive health.
Then after, I guess 15 years,
in that he started being
involved with a group that was
making TV programs and radio
dramas in developing countries
and that are on social issues of
things that are troubling the
societies in which they're shown
to.
Eventually he founded this
group, The Population Media
Center, and is both the founder
and the President of PMC.
These soap operas are different
than the kind of soap operas
that we're used to in America.
Their purpose is to explore
this social change and deal with
the issues that are of great
currency for developing
countries where the cultures are
changing rapidly in one
direction or another,
or not changing rapidly as the
case may be.
One of the big foci is women's
reproductive issues,
population issues,
HIV issues, child bride issues,
all the kinds of--a lot of the
ones that we've been talking
about in the class.
What's nice about him,
and due to his Yale training of
course,
is that both in the design of
these programs,
he uses really good academic
research,
what's really known about
social change and the induction
of social change,
they just don't go off and be
artsy-fartsy about anything.
They really study what is the
successful way of doing this.
Not only that,
then there's really three
stages of professionalism.
One, understanding the academic
stuff so you know what you're
doing,
then getting the very best
people in whatever country
you're working in,
the real good actors,
the major producers,
and groups that really know
what they're doing in terms of
entertainment and that leads to
great success,
which he'll describe.
Then further,
the third step,
is once you've done it,
did it work,
and that's the real serious
research, finding out if you've
done something.
You're hoping to incorporate
some sort of social change,
well did it work?
That's not easy,
but again Bill's group has used
the most careful and stringent
academic research to try to get
at that issue.
These programs have turned out
to be very popular successes and
you will hear about that and
they have indeed been successful
in fostering social change.
I put Bill into the category of
'people who have made a
difference.'
This is not a huge category,
and so I'm very proud--to
introduce him to you.
William Ryerson:
Bob, thank you very much,
pleasure to be with you.
As Bob said,
I started my career here at
Yale as a graduate student in
ecology and evolution,
and it was just 40 years ago
last October that I sat in the
audience at the Forestry School
and heard Paul Ehrlich talk
about his then recently
published book,
The Population Bomb.
He had been invited to give
that lecture by Charles
Remington who founded this
course,
and who was,
along with Paul and an attorney
from Connecticut named--
whatever his name was,
an attorney from Connecticut,
along with Paul and Charlie
Remington,
founded Zero Population Growth
immediately after the lecture
that Paul gave.
I had dinner with Paul at
Remington's house that night,
got very interested in--Dick
Bowers was the attorney's name.
I knew it would come to me
sooner or later when those
synapses connected.
--I had dinner with Ehrlich at
Remington's house that night,
took a huge interest in this
issue, which of course continues
to this day.
We're growing by the equivalent
of a new Egypt every year on a
global level,
about 82 million net growth and
the environmental impact of that
growth is immense.
I began, at that point,
to think about how to address
population issues,
how to try to bring about a
slowing of population growth
rates,
and how to also ameliorate the
impact of humans on the planet.
The conventional wisdom at the
time was to set up family
planning clinics,
which indeed was a good idea.
A lot of that happened,
particularly in the 1970s with
strong financial support and
leadership from the
U.S. Government,
something that changed over the
last few decades but is coming
back into popularity with the
new administration.
Indeed, what became evident,
even in the 1970s,
was that the solution was not
just the medical model,
setting up family planning
clinics.
Indeed, there was a need to get
people to use them.
There was great progress made,
particularly in the 1970s in
meeting the already existing
demand,
so we went from 10% of the
world's couples using modern
methods of contraception in 1960
to somewhere in the 40% in the
late 1970s and then since then
it has crept up to 55% of adult
couples using modern methods.
The 45% non-users,
however, outnumber the 90%
non-users of 1960 because of
population growth.
We have as big a problem ahead
of us as we did in 1960,
but we also have another
problem, which is the reasons
that they give for non-use.
Back in the early 1960s the
primary reason was lack of
access to contraceptive methods.
Now, in country after country,
it's less than 2% who give that
as their reason,
and the number one reason is
wanting more children;
that is, the bulk of the
non-users of contraception.
When you take them out,
maybe 200 million couples,
there is another 100 million
that are not using contraception
but don't want an additional
pregnancy,
at least not in the next two
years,
which is the standard question
that's asked in demographic and
health surveys.
The top four reasons they give
for their non-use are fear of
side effects,
they've heard its dangerous,
male opposition,
religious opposition,
and fatalism.
Now a couple of stories about
these;
fear of side effects is
something that indeed has been
intentionally planted by some
religious zealots who are
spreading rumors,
particularly around east
Africa, that condoms contain the
AIDS virus,
so people are actually dying
because of this misinformation.
They're afraid of using
condoms, they have heard that
they contain the HIV virus,
and so they're having
unprotected sex and getting AIDS
and dying.
It's really a criminal
misinformation campaign
motivated by people who just
think artificial methods of
contraception are not a good
idea for theological reasons
that most of their victims don't
understand,
and, for that matter,
that I don't understand but
I've tried.
Male opposition is in
part--male opposition,
and it's in part lack of
communication between husbands
and wives.
So, sometimes,
in traditional societies,
women think their husbands are
opposed,
but they've never had a
conversation about it in their
married life because this is
something that they're
embarrassed to bring up.
Fatalism is the subject of a
very interesting paper by
Etienne Van Der Walt.
Prof: They've read it.
William Ryerson:
Oh, you've read it.
Okay so you know about fatalism
and beliefs that whatever God
has decided for you must be fine
without any idea that you have
the right and the ability to
determine--
your own outcomes of your
family life.
Then religious opposition,
when I say this in the mass
media I always draw a lot of
fire, but there is no religion
that is opposed to family
planning.
You may have heard otherwise.
There are religions,
like the Catholic Church and
some conservative mullahs in
Islam,
who are opposed to certain
methods of family planning,
but there is no religion that
is preaching that everybody
should have as many children as
possible.
Indeed, the Catholic Church is
in favor of people limiting
their childbearing to those they
can afford to care for and love.
The issue is what methods are
appropriate and certainly we
know from Catholic teachings
that methods that are considered
artificial are not approved.
But, indeed,
the church goes to great
lengths to teach what we used to
call the rhythm method,
periodic abstinence as a way of
avoiding unwanted or unplanned
pregnancy.
In the world of Islam there are
liberal thinkers who are Islamic
scholars,
like Kutbuddin Aziz of
Pakistan, who have written that
the Koran,
by calling on women to
breastfeed their infants for at
least two years,
is inherently endorsing family
planning.
The Koran doesn't mention
family planning,
but by asking that women
breastfeed their infants for two
years in low nutrition
societies,
this means the woman must avoid
pregnancy.
So there are in fact official
findings at Al-Iman University
to that effect.
Some Muslim countries are
making huge strides in adopting
family planning,
the leading one being Iran,
which is now down at
replacement level fertility.
In part, driven by the
Ayatollah's in that country who
are promoting family use.
In Pakistan now,
the mosques are handing out
contraception.
So there's a dramatic change
going on in the world of Islam.
Having been in the population
field for a long time,
I happened to go to the first
World Population Conference.
By the way, I got involved with
Ehrlich and Remington and
starting a Yale Chapter of Zero
Population Growth,
it no longer exists,
and ended up on the National
Executive Committee of that
organization.
I went to work with The
Population Institute in
Washington,
an organization which I now
also am President of,
as of six months ago,
just to keep me from running
out of things to do.
At this first world conference
on population,
held in Bucharest in 1974,
I took 65 students and 20
faculty members from around the
U.S.
to cover this event for
newspapers across the U.S.
Each of the students was
accredited with a particular
newspaper and they all went as
reporters,
and they filed daily reports,
and it literally generated
hundreds of news articles about
this conference.
Margaret Mead happened to be at
this conference,
as did a colleague of mine from
the institute,
David Poindexter who now is the
Honorary Chair of Population
Media Center.
The two of them looked at the
proposed plan of action that the
U.N.
had put together and found that
there was no reference to the
status of women.
So, they sat down and wrote a
paragraph about the status of
women and took it to Phil
Claxton, who was the head of the
U.S.
delegation, a staff member of
the State Department Under
Secretary General--I mean Under
Secretary of State Department on
Population Affairs.
They said, 'Phil,
the plan of action says nothing
about the status of women,
so we've written a paragraph,
could you please introduce this
in the planning session of the
intergovernmental meeting?'
He said, 'Well this is a
meeting about family planning,
what's the status of women got
to do with it?'
By 1994, the most recent
U.N. Conference,
which I also attended,
the world had come to recognize
that the status of women is
central to everything having to
do not only with population but
with economic development.
If you educate daughters,
you educate the families of the
future, whereas,
if you educate a man,
you educate a man.
There is a huge need to change
the bias among many people
around the world that their
daughter's place is in the
kitchen,
or for sale to some man in a
polygamous marriage,
and their son's place is in
school.
Indeed, promoting behavior
change in that area,
and the human rights of women
to play an equal role with their
husbands in making decisions
about family life is critically
important.
Now the first real interest I
took in the population field,
after hearing Ehrlich's talk
about the ecological impact of
human encroachment on the wild
lands of the planet,
and the threat to biodiversity,
was the impact of different age
structures of human populations
on economic welfare.
There is a Princeton--now
deceased Princeton demographer
and economist named Ainsley
Cole,
who did a lot of work in this
area and I wrote--
a paper at the Forestry School
about his studies of the
dependency ratios that grow from
different age structures.
That is to say,
the number of non-working
children per working adult,
and in very large family
societies,
i.e., rapid population growth
countries,
which are mostly low income,
people spend a very high
percentage of their income on
immediate survival needs of
their children,
food, housing, and clothing.
When they reduce family size,
even without any change in
family income,
there's money left over and
that money can be spent on
elective goods which stimulates
the manufacturing sector.
It can be invested in
education, it can be invested
through the government and
infrastructure,
both of those build economic
productivity.
Most important,
it can be saved and put into
investments or just savings
accounts that builds capital
that allows businesses to borrow
money and grow,
building employment.
Indeed, it's the lack of
capital in many poor,
rapid population growth,
countries that is keeping
business from expanding and
that,
as a result,
is leading to economic
stagnation.
When you look at the history of
the countries that have gone
from developing status to
developed status since World War
II,
South Korea,
Japan, Hong Kong,
Singapore,
Taiwan, The Bahamas,
and Barbados,
each of those countries first
instituted strong voluntary
family planning programs and
then their economies took off.
Because once the fertility rate
got down below about 2.3 money
was left over,
capital was formed,
businesses expanded,
and some of the Asian tigers,
China being the lead among
them,
now are undergoing rapid
economic growth for the same
reason.
Obviously, economic policies
and various other factors affect
this but demographics are a key
aspect of economic welfare.
Infrastructure is also,
as I mentioned,
a key issue for economic
productivity.
If you don't have roads to get
your crops or products to
market,
you don't have airports,
you don't have clean water,
and a lot of other things that
public infrastructure consists
of,
number one being education,
schools for the upcoming
generations,
then your economy is going to
falter.
The average developing country
spends $13,000 for public
infrastructure:
schools,
roads, municipal offices,
water, sewer,
etc., electricity over the
lifetime of each person,
so a per capita expenditure of
$13,000.
When you multiply $13,000 times
the net growth of the world's
population every year of 82
million, what do you get?
Have you done that in your head
already?
Its a trillion dollars a year.
The price tag just to keep per
capita infrastructure even in
countries around the developing
world is a trillion dollars a
year.
They are coming nowhere near
making this expenditure,
they can't;
they don't have that kind of
money, in part because of
economic stagnation.
That is being aggravated by
rural to urban migration and so
you see urban centers in
developing countries where the
urban infrastructure is totally
overwhelmed.
I was in Kinshasa a year and a
half ago,
in Democratic Republic of the
Congo,
and that's a city that has
infrastructure designed to
handle 600,000 people with ten
million people living there.
In fact, hundreds of thousands
of people are sleeping on open
ground;
they just have no place to
sleep.
The city floods every time it
rains.
There's inadequate sewage
protection--or sewage treatment.
And the nuclear power plant
that the Belgians,
in their wisdom,
put in before they left,
is sitting at the edge of an
erosion zone.
They don't have the money to
stop it so the plant is in
danger of falling over.
The environmental advisor to
the governor of Kinshasa state,
who met my plane,
said he's been trying to--
he and the governor have been
trying to get the President of
the country to shut the nuclear
power plant down because,
if it falls over,
it's going to make the whole
area,
including Brazzaville across
the river,
uninhabitable for thousands of
years.
But, the President won't shut
it down because he wants to get
enough nuclear by-product to
build a bomb so he can bomb
Rwanda,
because Rwanda has troops
operating in eastern Congo,
which I visited.
I was in Goma about a little
less than a year ago and I
thought Kinshasa was bad until I
got to Goma.
Goma is where the fighting has
been going on recently in North
Kivu Province.
Now when you see these extreme
examples of lack of
infrastructure you realize this
analysis by Ainsley Cole was
really prophetic.
Now the environmental impacts
that Paul Ehrlich talked about
have gone way beyond loss of
wild lands and threat to
biodiversity.
In fact, one of the biggest
environmental threats,
right now, is pumping out water
from underground aquifers,
80% of which is used for
irrigation.
In China, in India,
in the American Southwest,
in every continent on the
planet, because of our growing
population and the demand for
food,
which you may have noticed went
up in price recently,
the farmers of the world are
pumping out the underground
aquifers at rates higher than
the rate of replacement by
rainwater.
This is a classic example of
something that's not
sustainable.
It's like taking money out of
the bank to pay for your daily
living expenses.
You can only do that so long.
The water table in India is
dropping by ten feet a year.
A thousand farmers of India a
couple of weeks ago committed
mass suicide.
They are having crop failures
as they can no longer drill deep
enough to reach the water.
India's green revolution,
which bought India maybe 30
years of time,
according to Norman Borlaug who
won the Nobel Prize for his
research on high-yield wheat and
rice,
and by the way,
who is a member of our program
advisory board.
The green revolution crops are
dependent on high volumes of
water for irrigation and cheap
oil.
Not only to run the tractors
but to make pesticides and
fertilizer,
to keep these crops growing,
and in fact there's an article
in The New York Times
within the last week about the
coming failure of the green
revolution crops of India,
but every country,
or at least every continent,
is facing this problem.
The yellow river in China does
not reach the ocean two-thirds
of the year because it's all
being used for irrigation.
What is keeping the rivers of
India and China flowing
periodically is the melting of
the Himalayan glaciers that
occurrs seasonally and waters
those lands.
However, with climate change,
we're losing the glaciers and
when they disappear,
which will be in this century
at the rate things are going and
probably in the next three
decades,
that combined with inability to
find any more underground water
will lead to traumatic crises
with regard to food in Asia.
And, for that matter,
the same thing is happening in
Africa and we're losing farmland
in the American Southwest with
the same process going on.
This is a crisis in the making
of global proportions combined
with climate change which is
causing rainfall patterns to
change,
and in some places rainfall to
decrease.
Climate change is indeed the
very visible example of why our
current pattern is
unsustainable.
We are already above 350 ppm in
the atmosphere of carbon
dioxide.
That means, even if we stop
driving cars and stop heating
with oil tomorrow,
and we burn no more fossil
fuels of any kind,
we are already going to have
devastating climate change.
The arguments going on in the
halls of Congress are,
can we reduce the rate of
increase,
or can we maybe become so
efficient that we level off or
slightly decrease our rates of
greenhouse gas output?
This is like arguing over which
deck chairs to sit in on the
Titanic.
Unless we actually stop
producing greenhouse gases and
find technology to withdraw
carbon dioxide and methane from
the atmosphere,
the climate is going over a
cliff this century.
Now, don't slit your wrists,
there are things we can do.
We have the technology to solve
a lot of these problems and,
indeed, the population issue is
a clear cut example.
Population, by the way,
is a climate issue.
How many children you have is a
climate related decision because
if,
as an American,
Americans have the highest per
capita output of greenhouse gas,
you have two children each of
whom consume 10% less than you
do,
you're still creating an impact
on the environment.
If you have three children,
you and your partner or spouse
are more than replacing
yourselves,
and you're having a potentially
devastating impact on the
environment if a lot people make
the same decision.
Decisions on reducing family
size,
in developed countries in
particular,
are the least expensive
intervention we can make to
reduce impact on the climate.
Even in the developing world,
where population growth is
occurring the fastest,
the rather optimistic median
projection of the United Nations
between now and 2050 is the
addition of 2.5 billion people.
That's eight times the U.S.
population.
At the rates of greenhouse gas
output, on a per capita level,
it's the carbon equivalent of
adding two United States to the
planet.
If we don't solve the
population problem,
we're not going to solve the
climate crisis either,
so there are a whole bunch of
things facing us.
Now how do we address all of
these behavioral things,
including the behavior of
Americans?
Well clearly the mass media is
influential.
Is there anybody here who's
never watched television?
No, now when I grew up we did
not have a television.
They existed,
but my parents thought they
were a bad idea,
and they may have been right,
I don't know.
We went over to our friend's
house and watched TV,
but indeed, we listened to
radio programs and in many of
the developing world countries,
people still spend their
evenings listening to the radio
because they can't afford TVs.
In Ethiopia only 4% of the
population can afford a
television, but radio is
listened to by a vast majority
of the population.
In our programs we use
primarily radio,
although this methodology that
I'm going to tell you about came
out of the world of television.
These are the countries in
which we have been working.
We do long running serialized
dramas,
sometimes referred to as soap
operas,
in which characters evolve into
role models for the audience for
elevation of women's status,
daughter education,
use of family planning,
small family norms.
We're looking at the idea of
applying this strategy in the
United States to address climate
issues and teenage pregnancy
issues.
We also do talk shows.
We've produced print materials,
but it is the entertainment
serialized dramas that are on
primetime in these countries,
where we have the largest
audiences,
and therefore have the biggest
potential for impact.
The creator of this methodology
is a Mexican producer named
Miguel Sabido who was Vice
President of the biggest
commercial network in Mexico,
Televisa, until his retirement
in 1998.
In 1975, after looking at the
social learning theory of
Stanford psychologist Albert
Bandura,
who still is looking at how
role models influence behavior
psychologically,
still is teaching at Stanford,
and is probably the world's
best known psychologist and is
the most frequently cited
psychologist in professional
journal articles of those who
are living.
He went up to actually
interview Bandura and went back
to Mexico to create a program to
promote adult education.
He realized,
from his work in overseeing the
audience research division of
the network,
that his programs were having a
huge impact on audience members,
so why not use them for good.
He created a soap opera with
three subplots,
one of which had illiterate
characters in it and the other
two just were pure entertainment
with changes of fortune,
and cliffhangers at the end of
each episode,
and all the stuff that goes
along with a soap opera.
They were on at primetime,
or this program was on at
primetime, it was called Ven
Conmigo, and it pulled in
33% of the nation's viewers.
You know, melodrama is defined
as the battle of good versus
evil,
so the evil characters were
telling the illiterate
characters that they were too
old or too stupid to learn and
they should forget about that
and stick with what they had.
The positive characters are
saying there's a whole
infrastructure for adult
education,
you ought to give it a try,
and you can master it,
you're not stupid.
One by one these illiterate
characters decided to go to
classes,
sign up and take the courses,
and get their diplomas,
and when they did so their
lives improved and this huge
audience witnessed this.
Sabido then became intentional
in promoting this and he ran an
epilogue in which he gave
addresses of registration sites
for adult education.
This epilogue followed the
episode in which his most
popular character got his
diploma and it--
I don't speak Spanish and I
broke down in tears when I
watched this episode because
it's so emotional,
this man crying,
holding his diploma because
finally he can read all the
letters he's gotten over the
years from his granddaughter,
and then there's this epilogue.
‘Perhaps you too would
like to do what this man has
done,'
Sabido warned the Ministry of
Public Education.
He said, 'You may be aware of
the show I'm doing on Televisa,'
and they said,
'yes we like it very much,
and it's reinforcing our public
service announcements.'
He said, 'Well I may generate a
crowd because I'm going to run
an advertisement after an
upcoming episode in which I give
addresses of your registration
sites.
Can you handle a crowd?'
They said 'No problem.
Last year before your program
started we signed up 99,000
people so we're set up to handle
large numbers,' so he ran that
episode and the following day,
in a single day,
250,000 people came in to try
to register and he continued to
run epilogues for the remaining
weeks of that 260 episode
program.
By the time it was done 840,000
people had signed up for adult
education.
Then he did a program called
Acompá
ñame,
Come With Me,
that promoted family planning,
as a solution to a problem of
family harmony which is a
perfect subject for a melodrama;
a couple arguing over how many
children to have and how to stay
out of poverty and so on and
they ultimately adopt a method
of family planning and they live
happily ever after.
similar impact on family
planning use and it was during
that program that David
Poindexter,
my colleague at Population
Institute,
discovered Sabido doing this
program in 1976.
He did two things,
he convinced Emilio
Azcárraga who owned
Televisa to have Sabido do four
more telenovelas dealing with
teenage pregnancy prevention and
family planning promotion,
and he took Sabido to meet
Indira Gandhi in India.
I had been in India in 1975
when she imposed involuntary
sterilization around the country
and it caused the family
planning efforts in India to
collapse,
and she lost the next election
as she should have.
It was a total mess.
She was very concerned about
India's population problem but
she didn't try the right
strategy and ultimately she got
re-elected and before her
assassination,
Sabido was sitting in front of
her saying,
you don't need to use coercion,
you can role model this,
show people the benefits and
they'll decide for themselves
whether to do it.
They ended up being sent to the
head of the Indian Television
Authority.
Sabido trained a writer,
Manohar Shyam Joshi who did
India's first home grown soap
opera which had huge impacts.
it's the subject of a book
called, India's Information
Revolution.
It pulled in between 65% and
90% of anybody who had access to
TV.
It generated 400,000 letters
from viewers to the Indian
Television Authority,
half of them addressed to
characters by name,
with advice on who they should
marry and so on,
but a lot of testimonials on
how the program was impacting
the audience members.
I got very interested in this
strategy and got involved in
studying the second Indian soap
opera,
which had huge effects on its
230 million viewers with regard
to attitudes about age of
married women and acceptability
of women in the workplace
outside the home.
One of the reasons this
strategy has been so effective,
where it's been tried around
the world, is the long running
nature of the program.
Because you can't get somebody
from say the status of a woman
in Sudan to Gloria Steinem with
a 60 second public service
announcement or with a one hour
drama,
you really need time to bring
about meaningful change without
creating backlash.
By having gradual evolution of
the transitional characters and
only in response to situations
that the audience understands
and themselves are experiencing,
can you bring about meaningful
change.
The emotional content of
melodrama is also very important
for helping people remember what
they learned from the programs,
as well as remembering the
program itself.
Do you remember what you were
doing on the morning of
September 11,2001?
Do you remember as clearly what
you were doing on the morning of
September 10?
Now what psychologists tell us
is that emotional involvement
enhances memory.
So, if you're highly involved
emotionally,
in an emotionally based
melodrama and you learn lessons
from it,
you remember those for the rest
of your life.
But if it's intellectual blah,
blah, blah it may last not much
longer than the final exam,
and I'm probably guilty of that
myself.
There are several other
theories that Sabido
incorporated into a theoretical
framework,
both psychological and
communication theories for the
creation of this methodology.
I'm not going to take the time
now to talk about them but
they're very interesting,
and I recommend you download
this free book from our website
that has those theories spelled
out as well as examples of this
strategy as it's been applied
around the world.
Thato Ratsebe,
who is now working for
Population Media Center--she is
flying to Nairobi today.
In Tanzania,
in 1993, I took Everett
Rodgers,
who was then Associate Dean of
the Annenberg School of
Communications at the University
of Southern California,
and a research design scientist
from Minneapolis named Peter
Vaughn to help design an
experimental evaluation to
measure the effects of a Sabido
style radio serial.
It was the second one done in
Africa and it was broadcast with
this pattern.
You can see the transmitting
towers,
the dots, and the shaded areas
around them are where you could
hear the signal,
but we intentionally chose
early primetime when the tower
in Dodoma was broadcasting
locally produced music with no
social or health content.
Twice a week,
for two years,
a 208 episode program,
people in the shaded areas
heard Twende Na Wakati,
Let's Go With The Times
or Let's Be Modern,
while in the control area they
heard music.
Among the characters in this
program was a negative character
named Mkwaju.
He was an alcoholic truck
driver with a girlfriend at
every truck stop and a
subservient wife named Tunu
waiting at home.
He was, in Tanzanian society,
every man's ideal.
This guy was a sexual athlete,
he was having a wonderful time,
he had girlfriends everywhere
draping over him at every truck
stop,
and so it attracted a huge male
following,
more men than women in this
audience,
but overall 58% of the adult
population listening.
Much to Mkwaju's surprise,
he found he was married to a
transitional character.
And Tunu, perhaps having read
some of the thousands of letters
addressed to her coming into
radio Tanzania advising her that
her husband was cheating on her,
stood up to him when he was
home on one of his visits and
told him she had heard about the
AIDS epidemic.
She knew what he was up to on
the road and he was going to
have to use condoms,
and she made that happen.
She eventually took a job and
ultimately she founded her own
business and became a role model
for female entrepreneurship in
Tanzania.
Now if you're a scriptwriter
you probably figured out Mkwaju
becomes sick,
for some time the audience
doesn't know what has affected
him,
but they find out he now has
AIDS and Tunu throws him out,
but ultimately takes him back
and cares for him in a separate
bedroom until he dies.
The audience learned a few
lessons out of this.
We did a nationwide,
random sample survey of 2,750
people annually,
starting with a baseline just
before going on the air and then
repeated annually for four years
1993,
1994,1995, 1996 and 1997.
From 1993 to 1995 this was the
pattern of broadcasting.
From 1995 to 1997 we broadcast
the program in Dodoma,
so we were able to measure in
broadcast areas and
non-broadcast areas what was
going on with regard to self
reported knowledge,
attitudes and behavior.
I also got the Ministry of
Health to ask new family
planning adopters why they had
come to the clinics.
Now in the survey at the end of
year two,
58% of the adult population
listening,
82% of the listeners said the
program had caused them to
change their behavior to avoid
HIV infection.
We were astounded by how high
an impact it was.
The most common change people
said they had made was reduction
in the number of sexual
partners.
We didn't have the budget to
hire enough private detectives
to verify those claims,
but we got the condom
distribution data from the
National AIDS Control Program
broken down by district,
and in the districts that made
up the control area,
where they got all the national
programs about AIDS,
except for this soap opera,
there was a 16% increase in
condom and distribution,
while in the broadcast areas
there was 153% increase in
condom distribution.
Now when we took all of the
reported behavior changes across
the country and extrapolated it
to wherever you could hear this
program,
the cost per person who changed
behavior to avoid HIV infection
was $0.08 U.S.
On family planning we saw a 10%
increase in the number of family
planning adopters in the initial
broadcast areas and zero change
in the control area around the
Dodoma transmitter.
When we broadcast the program
in Dodoma, the following two
years we had a 16% increase in
family planning adoption.
And in both areas,
at the times the broadcasts
were on the air in those areas,
41% of the new adopters named
the program as their reason for
coming in.
The next most impactful
intervention was named by 11%,
so a 4:1 ratio of effects
between this soap opera and the
next most impactful
intervention.
Now it was right after seeing
this data that I started
Population Media Center and I
took Rose Haji,
who produced the Tanzanian
program,
Tom Kazungu who was the first
African trained by Sabido and
the first radio person to use
it,
and Sabido himself to Ethiopia.
We trained a team of writers to
produce two programs,
one in Amharic,
the national language which was
257 episodes long and the second
one 140 episodes in Oromiffa,
the second most common
language, and those were on the
air for two and a half years
starting in June of 2002.
The Amharic program was
listened to by 47% of men,
45% of women.
The Oromiffa program pulled in
another 25% of the population,
so we had well over 40 million
people listening to this
program.
It became the subject of daily
conversations,
as well as thousands of
letters;
15,000 poured into our office
in Addis Ababa during the time
these programs were on the air.
Most of them in response to the
Amharic language program which
had a better time slot.
One of those letters was from a
woman who said she was so happy
we had addressed the issue of
marriage by abduction because,
you may not know this,
but in rural Ethiopia the
status of women is so low that
it's considered socially
acceptable for a man to grab a
girl off the street.
And I mean a school girl,
take her home and rape her,
and then she's considered to be
his wife and she's stuck with
her abductor for the rest of her
life.
And parent's won't take the
daughters back because they're
damaged goods and it would bring
shame on the family.
So they leave the girls with
these abductors.
Now this is starting to change
and courts are starting to allow
these women to escape.
We dealt with this in this very
popular program and this letter
said,
'Thank you so much for dealing
with the issue of marriage by
abduction through your character
Wubahn.
Our own daughter was abducted
on her way to school at age 14
and ended up married as a result
and we've been afraid to send
our 12 year old girls to school
for fear the same thing would
happen to them.
When your program played and
dealt with this issue the entire
village which had listened to
it,
came together,
and we agreed to enforce the
law against marriage by
abduction and it's now safe to
send our 12 year old girls to
school.'
This is the kind of qualitative
information we got from those
letters.
We also had listening groups
that filled out diaries after
each episode and periodic focus
group discussions for feedback
to the writers,
and monitoring through 14,400
exit interviews at reproductive
health clinics to ask people why
they had come,
and a baseline and
post-broadcast quantitative
survey across the country.
At the 48 clinics where those
14,000 exit interviews were
carried out,
63% of the new reproductive
health clients were listening to
the program or one of the
programs,
and over a fourth of the new
clients cited one of the
programs as the primary
motivator for seeking services.
Radio Ethiopia has 100% public
service broadcasting and a lot
of programs dealing with AIDS
and family planning.
Of all the people who named
Radio Ethiopia or other radio
programs,
96% named one of our programs,
4% named any of the other
programs on the radio as their
source of motivation.
This shows increase in use of
family planning from baseline to
non-listeners to listeners,
the increase among the
listeners was more than double
the increase among non-listeners
and highly statistically
significant.
Some of the non-listeners were
clearly motivated through
conversations with listeners.
Now this is a decrease in not
knowing how to determine ones
HIV status and this is actual
reporting of going for HIV
testing: male listeners sought
HIV tests at four times the rate
of non-listeners;
female listeners sought tests
at three times the rate of
non-listeners.
Now we've done similar work in
these countries.
In Vietnam we're currently on
the air with a program dealing
with HIV/Aids on The Voice of
Vietnam.
In West Africa we did a program
dealing with child slavery.
It was actually something that
was brought about through a
request by Ben &
Jerry's and funding from them
to get started and then funding
from the U.S. Government.
We measured a quintupling of
awareness among listeners of the
problem of child
trafficking/child slavery and a
doubling of interventions by
listeners to stop the practice.
We've just gone on the air in
Mali with a program promoting
family planning.
We've done two programs in
Nigeria,
the first one was at the
request of the Rotarian Action
Group on Population and
Development that was setting up
a surgery to offer repair for
women who have obstetric
fistula,
something that results from the
daughter's in northern Nigeria
being married off at age 9 and
getting pregnant at age 12,
and trying to deliver with an
immature pelvis and having
obstructed labor,
and ending up somewhat torn to
shreds and incontinent.
These girls married to older
men in polygamous marriages
generally then get thrown out on
the street and live as beggars,
and the Rotary Clubs of
northern Nigeria set up a
surgical center to repair them
because,
for $300, these women can be
returned to a normal life.
If they are unrepaired,
they're incontinent and they
live on the streets,
and they smell bad,
and they're social pariahs.
In fact, there are 800,000
women in Nigeria with unrepaired
fistulas.
We were able to measure,
by promoting family planning,
and delaying marriage and
childbearing to adulthood,
a third of the women coming to
family planning clinics named
our program as their reason for
coming,
and 54% of the women coming for
surgical repair named the
program as the reason they were
at the clinic.
The second program,
that's on the air currently,
is being named by 67% of family
planning adopters as their
motivation for seeking services.
In Rwanda, currently 57% of
family planning clients and 59%
of HIV testing clients name our
program as their motivation for
coming to the clinic.
We're also using the program to
promote preservation of mountain
gorilla habitat,
and more generally,
wilderness areas in Rwanda.
In Sudan, the program addressed
the issue of female genital
mutilation.
Opposition to FGM in Sudan at
the time that program was on the
air went from 28% to 65% by the
end of the program.
In Niger we dealt with child
trafficking also and in Senegal
we've just gone on the air with
two programs in two different
languages.
In the U.S.
we're working with the
Hollywood community,
in partnership with the Academy
of Television Arts &
Sciences and the Screenwriter's
Guild of America.
We've done two briefings for
members of the Screenwriter's
Guild,
the most recent one on climate,
population,
health and security issues,
we held in Hollywood in
November and the one before that
about a year and a half ago at
Emory School of Public Health
looking at the role of
entertainment television and
addressing public health issues.
These are countries in which we
are developing projects.
I was in Papua,
New Guinea and Uganda in the
development of new projects in
the last two months,
but we have projects in various
stages of development in each of
these countries.
Now how are we on time?
Why don't I take just a few
minutes and show you,
if I can make this work,
a clip from a documentary done
by a CNN Vice President for
Environment,
no longer with CNN but she was
head of Environment for CNN and
Turner Broadcasting.
A woman named Barbara Pile who
did a documentary on this idea
of social content soap operas in
the Philippines where Cecil
Alvarez produced a program.
I'm not sure if I'm going to be
able to put this on full screen
but let's see.
This is a documentary about
this Philippine program
introduced by Jane Fonda and
then the documentary is by
Barbara Pile.
The storyline is about two
sisters,
one of whom elopes at I think
the age of 16 and has a baby
every year trying to please her
husband who wants a son and it's
a tragedy
<<video clip
54:25-1:01:50>>
Well that fixed that.
Are there lights?
Thank you.
That's a half hour documentary
but you saw the part about it
that is on that soap opera,
and I guess with that I thank
you for your attention and I'd
be happy to take questions.
Are there any questions or
comments?
Prof: What happened that
there's so--in America you have
a soap opera once a week for an
hour--
William Ryerson:
Well some are daily.
Prof: Some are daily?
William Ryerson:
Daytime.
Prof: You see those too,
right?
How is it that--is that the
standard mood in
>?
William Ryerson:
It varies all over the
place.
In Latin America,
its daily, daytime and
primetime.
In many countries it's twice a
week.
Some are once a week,
but once a week is really not
adequate because you have to
hold the audiences interest for
a whole week waiting for the
resolution of the latest
cliffhanger,
so we like to do a minimum of
twice a week,
and some of them are three
times a week.
Yes.
Student:  If you--if
you're like having a program for
like two years how do you draw
people in and say it's halfway
through the show or a quarter
ways, how do you continue to
inspire the new audience?
William Ryerson:  Well--
The question was how do we deal
with people who are drawn into
the program halfway through a
two-year soap opera?
The answer is one of the
beauties about having several
hundred episodes is you can have
a lot of discussion of what's
gone on in the past by the
characters,
so people who join the audience
partway through the two or three
years that it might be on the
air learn a lot about it and
they also may learn about it
from other members of the
community.
Particularly in countries where
we have very high listenership,
like northern Nigeria,
our most recent measure was 82%
of the adult population is
listening every week.
There it's become a cultural
event,
so people who are joining it
hear both about the program from
their neighbors,
as well as hearing characters
talking about the past and
getting caught up that way.
One of the questions I'm often
asked and maybe I should wait
until somebody asks me this
question is how do we decide
what it is we're promoting.
In a sense, what gives us,
as an American organization,
the right to go into some
country and tell them how to
live?
Indeed, one of the things that
we've adopted as a strategy is
looking at the policies of each
country;
most countries are signatories
of the Cairo Program of Action
on Population and Development,
and of the Beijing Platform of
Action on Women's Rights.
If they're a signatory of those
documents then part of their
national policy is incorporated
in those documents which are
really global agreements on the
rights and status of women and
reproductive health.
So, we use that as a starting
point as the basis for the
values that will be promoted by
the program.
Then the policies of the
country may add nuances to that,
so when we go into a country,
we explain to them we are there
to help them promote their
policies,
we're not trying to impose
something from the outside.
Yes.
Student:  Well I was
going to actually ask how--do
you find that you have a lot of
opposition from governments or
other institutions?
William Ryerson:
Hardly any.
The question was do we
have opposition from
governments?
One of the things about this
strategy is, because we're
working to support the
government's policies,
they are very enthusiastic
about it.
Second, we get very little
opposition from the public
because of the very gradual
evolution of the characters and
because,
by doing our homework and
really understanding the culture
before we ever get started,
and having writers from that
culture,
all of our programs are
written, produced,
and managed by country
nationals.
We know what the taboos are and
we steer clear of those,
so we're not there to give
people shock therapy,
we're there to start where they
are and move in the direction of
better reproductive health and
women's rights.
We don't do it in a way that
creates backlash or opposition.
Yes.
Student:  The Twilight
books and Seventh Heaven,
shows like that,
I was wondering if people say
that they are--
they were made to promote
things like abstinence and
Seventh Heaven was always
doing 'don't drink,
don't smoke' episodes.
I'm wondering how you think
they relate to the programs that
you guys show?
William Ryerson:
The question is,
with American shows like
Seventh Heaven are we--
what's the comparison between
their strategy for promoting not
drinking and driving,
or abstinence with the kinds of
programs we're doing?
The answer is,
there is some comparison.
That is, producers and writers
of American Hollywood shows are
members of society and they're
parents and they're very aware
of some of the problems,
and sometimes they attempt to
address issues in the context of
their program.
We had Neil Bear as a speaker
at an event we did at Hofstra
University about a month ago who
produces Law &
Order and also was a
producer of ER,
and there are very intentional
efforts to use some of these
programs to promote positive
goals.
They tend to do so in one or a
few episodes as opposed to
having a program that's designed
around a set of issues,
so it tends to be briefer
mentions of these issues and
sometimes they're done well and
sometimes they're not.
Indeed, there are lots of
examples of entertainment shows
in Hollywood like the Bold
& The Beautiful
addressing HIV/AIDS through a
character named Tony who finds
out he's HIV positive.
They got an 800 number from
Donna Shalala when she was
Secretary of Health &
Human Services that they could
run after those key episodes for
people to call for information.
That show generated more calls
to that 800 number than the
60 Minutes' treatment of
HIV/AIDs and 60 Minutes
has a much bigger audience,
but it was the emotional impact
of Days of Our Lives that
generated a huge response by the
audience.
So, some of these have been
very useful interventions,
but they're quite different in
terms of methodology.
Yes?
Student:  Do you do
follow up studies and is there
any evidence to show that the
contraception doesn't just
like--
increase immediately after the
show but continues years after
the shows have gone off the air.
William Ryerson:
There is some evidence.
Of course you're asking a
fundraising question.
It is hard to get grants for
say a ten year study,
but there is some evidence.
For example,
with Sabido's family planning
programs,
they stopped addressing family
planning issues at Televisa,
unrelated to the controversy or
not of the content.
They stopped doing social
content broadcasting at Televisa
in 1985, and the birthrate had
come down dramatically.
It was the most dramatic
decline in birthrates of any
developing country in the
twentieth century during the ten
years Sabido's five family
planning soap operas were on the
air.
When they stopped,
the birthrate plateaued,
but it did not go back up.
However, our view is because
there are new generations coming
along every year,
and because people continue to
need information on a whole
range of health and social
issues,
these programs should be seen
as a long-term intervention.
We shouldn't say do a program
for three years and then walk
away,
in the same way that we
wouldn't open a clinic for three
years and then close it down and
hope that the birthrate wouldn't
go back up.
We really see this as a long
term intervention,
but the evidence that we have
is probably not conclusive,
but it appears that these
programs lead to permanent
change in norms.
Yes?
Student:  Do you ever
find yourself at a competitive
disadvantage to the more
traditional commercial soap
operas?
William Ryerson:
Certainly in countries
that have a mature media market
like India,
like Brazil,
we are adopting more a strategy
of working with the producers of
existing programs than trying to
produce our own and compete.
In Brazil, for example,
we're working in partnership
with the social merchandising
department of TV Globo,
which controls 65% of the
Brazilian audience.
That strategy--actually their
department emerged because of
the partnership we formed
originally through a meeting
David Poindexter and I had with
Roberto Murino who owned the
network and it was being done
through the product placement
division.
But ultimately they set up a
whole division to promote social
causes through the telenovelas,
and so we helped them do that
and we measure the effects.
For example,
36% of the women at Planned
Parenthood clinics in Brazil
were there because of one soap
opera we evaluated called
Paginas Da Vida,
Pages of Life.
It's similar to what we're
doing in Hollywood.
We're not--We may do a You Tube
soap opera,
but we're not likely to get
ourselves on the air on CBS,
so we're instead focusing on
working with writers of existing
programs.
Yes?
Student:  I'm curious
about the range of social issues
of your audiences.
I mean if they're writing into
the characters and addressing
them by name and giving
suggestions,
they may not be so savvy about
the media,
I'm wondering if that helps or
hinders your project or both?
William Ryerson:
It's a question that we
try to understand before we ever
go on the air,
what are their attitudes,
perceptions of,
and consumption of
entertainment media.
Indeed, the audience is,
in terms of their
sophistication and their media
savvy varied dramatically from a
place like Ethiopia to a place
like India.
There's no one generalization,
but there are many stories
about our experiences in
Ethiopia.
For example,
the actress who played the
positive female role model
Furkurta in that first program I
was talking about,
went into a vegetable market
and women recognized her voice
from the radio show,
and one of them said you're
Furkurta and she said,
well not really,
and they said no,
no,
no we know you're Furkurta,
we recognize you from Yeken
Kignit,
and one of them said,
I named my baby daughter after
you in hopes that she would be
as wonderful as you are.
Clearly there--they are not
seeing the distinction between
fantasy and reality,
but on the other hand,
how many times have you heard
this about American audiences?
It's hard to know really,
but clearly,
probably the lack of
sophistication leads to greater
influence of the programs but
it's hard to know.
One more question.
Student:  How do you
feel applying those models to
other social issues such as
environmental degradation?
Because it--I mean family
planning is really based on
family relationships and how
people relate to each other and
how do you see--
I guess how do you--what's your
belief of what the success rate
of these programs will be--
if it's more on environment
issues or other type of social
justices?
William Ryerson:
The question is how do we
feel about applying the strategy
to other issues like environment
as opposed to family life and
family planning issues?
The answer is we feel great
about it,
however, you point out it might
not be the most exciting soap
opera to do a soap opera on
recycling,
so it doesn't have the same sex
appeal or audience appeal as a
program about people's lives,
so we mix issues and we like to
do programs about life in the
country.
In the eastern Caribbean,
the nine countries where we're
broadcasting a program,
that program is addressing both
family planning and preservation
of the rain forests of the
eastern Caribbean.
In Rwanda, similarly.
We're planning a program in
Papua New Guinea that will
address conservation of marine
resources and family planning.
Clearly, family life issues are
a perfect subject for melodrama.
You have to be very careful how
much conservation kinds of
content you put into a program,
but indeed, you can have the
life of a village in a soap
opera,
and for example,
in Papua, New Guinea one of the
fishing practices that is
clearly a short term strategy is
to use dynamite to blow up the
reef and it stuns all the fish
and they can scoop them out of
the ocean.
That's not a sustainable
livelihood,
so we can demonstrate that
through a two year soap opera in
a way that might take many more
years and be devastating to the
marine environment if it--
if people just wait until
they're starving.
The point is well taken,
it's something where we have to
be careful not to overload it
with messages and boring
information,
it really has to remain an
exciting program or we'll lose
our audience.
Well I think we better call it
quits because we're past
adjournment time.
I thank you all very much.
>